>>> RICKY MARTIN IS EXPECTED TO
APPEAR IN COURT IN PRTO RICO
AFTER HE WAS SERVED R A
RESTRAINING ORDER FOR ALLEGED
HARASSMENT.
>> MARTIN'S 21-YEAR-OLD NEPHEW
MADE THE ACCUSATIONS BUT MARTIN
IS NOW VEHEMENTLY DENYING THESE
HARASSMENT ACCUSATIONS AND SAID
HE WAS NOT INVOLVED IN A
ROMANTIC RELATIONSHIP WITH HIS
NEPHEW.
THE ALLEGATIONS ARE, OBVIOUSLY,
STUNNING.
IT'S A COMPLEX LAW BECAUSE IT'S
A DOMESTIC ABUSE LAW BUT THESE
ARE NOT ALLEGATIONS OF DOMESTIC
ABUSE IN THE TRADITIONAL SENSE.
THERAPY HARASSMENT ALLEGATIONS.
>> EXACTLY RIGHT.
>> WHERE DO THINGS STAND?
>> THIS IS WHAT IS INTERESTING.
I SPOKE WITH THE POLICE LAST
NIGHT IN SAN JUAN, PUERTO RICO.
THEY TOLD ME THIS IS EX PARTE
ORDER.
IT'S LIKE THE UNITED STATES.
ONE PARTY GOES TO COURT AND THEY
ALLEGE AND THEY HAVE THEIR
EVIDENCE AND THEY ALLEGE BEFORE
A JUDGE THAT THEY WANT AN ORDER
SO SOMEONE STAYS AWAY FROM THEM.
THE POLICE TOLD ME IT WAS
GRANTED AND THE POLICE TOLD ME
THAT IT IS THEIR KNOWLEDGE THAT
THE ALLEGATION WAS THAT THIS
NEPHEW AND MARTIN WERE IN A
RELATIONSHIP.
THAT RELATIONSHIP ENDED AND THEN
TWO MONTHS AFTER THAT, THE
NEPHEW WENT TO COURT TO GET THAT
DOMESTIC ORDER.
NOW, WE ALSO DO KNOW THAT THE
OTHER SIDE, MARTY SINGER, THE
ATTORNEY, IS VERY STRONGLY
DISCOUNTING ANY OF THIS.
I WANT TO READ TO YOU.
IT SAYS RICKY MARTIN HAS NEVER
BEEN AND NEVER WOULD BE INVOLVED
IN ANY KIND OF SEXUAL OR
ROMANTIC RELATIONSHIP WITH HIS
NEPHEW.
THE IDEA IS NOT ONLY UNTRUE, IT
IS DISGUSTING AND WE HOPE THAT
THIS MAN GETS HELP HE SO
URGENTLY NEEDS.
MOSTLY WE LOOK TO THIS AWFUL
CASE BEING DISMISSED AS SOON AS
A JUDGE GETS TO LOOK AT THE
FACTS.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT RICKY MARTIN
WENT TO TWITTER AND HE HAS SAID
THAT THIS IS COMPLETELY FALSE.
ANY ALLEGATION IN THIS CASE.
I APPRECIATE THE GESTURES.
THERE IS A LAW IN PUERTO RICO
AND THEY ARE SAYING THAT THEY
ARE, IN FACT, WAS THIS
RELATIONSHIP AND THAT WHEN IT
ENDED, THAT RICKY MARTIN
ALLEGEDLY KEPT GOING TO THE HOME
OF THIS NEPHEW THAT HE JUST
COULDN'T GET OVER WHAT HAD
ENDED.
SO THAT SORT OF GOES ALONG WITH
WHAT THE POLICE IS SAYING.
NEXT WEEK, THERE WILL BE
HEARING.
AT THAT HEARING, BOTH SIDES WILL
THAN PRESENT AND BE ABLE TO GIVE
THEIR SIDE AND RICKY MARTIN'S
ATTORNEY WILL BE THERE BUT IT
COULD BE VIRTUAL AND THEY DON'T
HAVE TO BE IN PERSON.
>> THANK YOU, JEAN, FOR THE
REPORTING, FOR THE FACTS, FOR
THE HOURS YOU SPEND ON THE PHONE
WITH THE AUTHORITIES.
WE APPRECIATE IT.